look at this be hi guys usually today
would be a Friday or a video but this
week I have shot absolutely nothing for
fried area I don't know why that
happened I dunno why I just I didn't do
it that's why tomorrow morning I will be
on a flight to Toronto and then I'm
going out of town for my birthday so I
didn't want to leave you guys with no
video so instead I have an alternative
video I'm gonna do Chester sees makeup I
agreed to this hey I used to put makeup
on every day in my life
you should get your contacts six days I
had glitter lipstick yeah I tried this
block that part out you wanna am 12:55
yeah big dad I don't know that I have
colors that match your skin
appropriately but we'll try yeah this
doesn't feel as for as uh your native oh
this feels for me hey we are from very
different ethnic backgrounds drink down
I'm gonna put a darker color in with
this stupid it's already doing
everything I hoped it would do it just
make me laugh yeah right Tony I'm gonna
makeup artists
oh I gambled okay how from doing your
makeup is fixing all of the mistakes no
that's not how that's all of doing your
makeup it's just fixing mistakes
ron's ER will make it different we'll
get to bronzing it up and making it even
better we're gonna now fix your
under-eye circles okay I don't have
under-eye circles
I got all the crow's feet okay look up
okay
did you do it you look gorgeous tonight
okay now gonna add bronzer to you
hopefully that'll fix everything what
kind of makeup did you use yourself
you'd be really great at a favorites
video when I was wearing the most makeup
with the Disney days really because they
were aging me down oh yeah this is the
point of makeup to make you look younger
wow wow wow look at that goddamn I'm
gonna fix your eyebrows that's what I'm
gonna do my god your eyebrows are gonna
get beautiful hey guys um man you don't
need make-up to show how young you are
just use your vocabulary I know you can
apply it to a lot other things I know
that it's already kind of like coming on
you know that when you talk you furrow
your whole head I got I got I put a lot
of motion is to it you have pretty good
eyebrows are very full thank you I know
what I do have the inability to keep
your eye back
laughing oh no no no what I do have that
some girls have been jealous of oh we'll
get to your eyelashes don't worry I got
some brand is the best thing to remember
is that your eyebrows are sisters and
not twins
look at that goddamn now we're gonna do
eyeshadow I'm gonna give you a smokey
eye because I have to I used to get
myself a little smokey eye you have tiny
eyelids maybe I don't have big eyelashes
maybe it's just relative to my tiny
eyelids I feel like they're gonna hire
you
Hedwig I'm gonna do eyeliner now and
this is gonna be a disaster
yes careful just liquid eyeliner yes
that's great it's good to move on oh you
know we're gonna do we're gonna do
mascara now we should curl your lashes
maybe record your lashes before so just
look down have to make one of the things
okay look down but don't close your eyes
till you don't gone dumb wow that's
terrifying to do to someone else I don't
know how my cap artists have ever done
that on me before whoa I just blank a
bunch holy shock your eyelashes are
super long
really Wow Wow
can you even handle yourself I'm going
to put blush on myself or blush just
your smile like this I guess yeah they
look like what's the animal that you
look like my sister think I look like a
gopher it is very accurate to do your
lipstick oh you're done all right yeah
you're having fun too much so just relax
your mouth dad keep your tongue in your
mouth
are you really pretty just a train
yeah yeah I don't know how well you
didn't blend it oh yeah it feels like
I'm a little patchy
wow the wig might make you look more
masculine you look actually very similar
to me I had brown hair
what would my yeah would be my like
female name is Anna Tina used to me I
can't choose that for you why don't you
guys tell us leave a comment down below
what would Chester sees female name be
don't go Chester Reena too obvious let
me try really hard to not this is a
really tough one to not look at this
black girl [ __ ] high it's really hard
to avoid a beautiful am I'm trying to
stare anything can we try the other make
tas's like Shirley Temple like 50 years
in the future and super fun not go well
for Shirley where this gets any weirder
I'm gonna say goodbye now thank you for
letting me do your makeup Chester see um
anything else you'd like to add I don't
know